build it dry fly it
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is bdp build it Colin Furze built
his own jet engine and puts it on
everything
he made a jet-powered snow blower a jet
powered bicycle drove a mobility scooter
70 miles per hour in the snow and also
made a video about building a jet engine
with a drill grinder and toilet brush
holder his most recent video is the cake
o matic in which eight spoons one cake
and a lot of power feeds him his
birthday cake sort of check out his
youtube channel for more victor sona
creates these twisted bike sculptures
that he feels represent life's ride he
uses old parts to create them and says
that society is not defined by what we
create but by what we refuse to destroy
some models include the Guernica the
persistence of memory and boogie-woogie
Mandy Smith uses sandpaper to transform
everyday objects into uncomfortable
creations all of these objects take on a
much different feeling once made out of
sandpaper such as a slide a bed and
toilet paper draw ondrea's england
created this aging superhero series
where he chronicles the life and times
of a superhero from his young days
getting caught by the paparazzi and
having a hangover - having a baby and
becoming an old man I fought the law is
a photo series by Olivia Locker
dramatizing strange state laws for
instance in Alabama it's illegal to have
an ice-cream cone in your back pocket
okay others include laws from Hawaii
Connecticut Delaware Texas Wisconsin and
California and now for the last supper
by platen over Nathalia illustrations of
different versions of the Last Supper
creatively placed on No
mark Wagner created this intricate art
series using $1 bills that plays with
the concept that money is just another
material the pieces themselves are all
closely related to currency such as
wealth and the division of wealth and
capitalism playing Kaleb does incredible
death metal clarinet covers here's his
version of spheres of madness by
decapitated
Andrew Wong performs an entire rap song
without ever using the letter e lap song
in which no lyrics contain that v
capital brains of his magical estranged
magicals playing deaf it's any occasion
I put scripts birthday see kids chips my
gigs absurd patreon gigs of Thursday
shall be a big horseplay metronome
created this amazing electronic remix of
the Breaking Bad theme now say my name
finally life is music by Sauer features
a spinning CD as a phenakistoscope using
189 CDs
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo w/o
you
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi an entire video dedicated to
just your creations and as always thanks
for watching
it was only the little girl who saw the
one flower fall from the tree
the girl picked up the flower and looked
at it what makes you so special she
asked the flower said nothing for it is
not no dance the girl decided to climb
the trees to return the flower to its
rightful place